all right I'll become the new open AI
CEO they've asked me for so many years
to do it I've always said no I don't
have time I have to attend the paper
discussions on our Discord server every
Saturday night and you know just just
don't have the capacity to also do do
this I'll do it you have me this comes
in the wake of an announcement on the
open AI blog uh that says after you know
Critical examination
by the board after a deliberate review
press process concluded that Sam Alman
was not consistently candid in his
Communications with the board hindering
its ability to exercise its
responsibilities the board no longer has
confidence in his ability to continue
leading open AI open AI is essentially
firing Sam Alman Sam Alman departs the
company he is being gone he joben Miram
morati is appointed the interim CEO
while open AI is looking for a new one
they have not yet announced my uh
accepting of this as I've just done it
in this video what happened here this
blog post comes as a surprise to almost
everyone including as we'll see Sam
Alman including Microsoft uh including
open AI employees and so on the Board of
open AI is a pretty complicated
construct in terms of their company
structure but essentially it is the body
that governs open Ai and they have
ousted Sam Alman he himself has released
a tweet or an X or whatever that's
called now uh saying I loved my time at
open AI it was transformative for me
personally and hopefully the world a
little bit most of all I loved working
with such talented people will have more
to say about what's next later signing
off Greg Brockman who W is was the
chairman of the board of open AI
tweeting this saying after I learned
today's news this is the message I sent
to the open AI team hi everyone I'm
super proud of what we've all built
since starting in my apartment 8 years
ago yada yada yada but based on today's
news I quit so Greg quitting Sam being
jobin and Sam then later also tweeting
out that today was a weird experience
it's sort of like reading your own
eulogy while you're still alive the
outpouring of Love Is Awesome of all the
people wishing him well and thanking him
for his service at open AI lot of
speculation I love you all spells Ilia
people have been asking what's behind
this why is Sam Alman being fired from
open Ai and one speculation is in fact
that Ilia satk is behind sort of an
overturning of power inside of open AI
uh Greg Brockman later released a tweet
detailing a little bit of the timeline
of what happened here Greg saying samai
are shocked and saddened by what the
board did today we're still trying to
figure out what exactly happened here is
what we know that being said Greg
Brookman was the chairman of the board
of open AI uh so this is all the more
mysterious that he himself wasn't
involved in any of this this seems like
quite a back room deal uh that was being
done here to overturn the power
structure inside of open AI saying last
night Sam got a text from Ilia asking to
talk at noon Friday Sam joined a Google
meet and the whole board except Greg was
there so Greg being himself Elia told
Sam he was being fired and that the news
was going out very soon at 9 12: p.m.
Greg got a text from Elia so this was
supposedly 19 minutes after Sam was
informed asking for a quick call at
12:23 Ilia sent a Google meet link now
people already going around saying never
join an impromptu Google meet Greg was
told that he was being removed from the
board but was vital to the company and
would retain his role so just the board
membership would be removed and that Sam
had been fired around in the same time
openai published a blog post as far as
we know the management team was made
aware of this shortly after other than
mea who found out the night prior
Microsoft shortly after that releasing a
statement uh that they are committed to
delivering all of this with to the
customer all of what they've presented
in the week prior we have a long-term
agreement with open AI with full access
to everything we need to deliver on our
Innovation agenda and exciting product
road map remain committed to our
partnership and Tamira and the team
together will continue to deliver yada
yada yada so Microsoft essentially
saying like you know don't worry
everyone just because Sam and Greg are
leaving open AI we are open AI is still
bound to us we still have all the access
to Tech that we need and to the models
to upcoming models so that we can
deliver on all the things we promis to
deliver it's as of yet get unclear if
Microsoft benefits from this or not and
that goes a bit to the core of you know
what actually happened and why it
happened all of what we're going to talk
today except a few you know confirmed
facts are total speculation don't
believe anything as of now the story is
still super developing but we can dive a
little bit into what we know according
to Forbes investors did not know that
any of this was going to to happen in
this case it seems like the board of
directors which consists of a fairly
random sample of people just made this
decision Ox is also reporting Microsoft
was blindsided by open ai's AER of CEO
Sam Alman a lot of people when it comes
to the relation of open Ai and Microsoft
point to the open ai's structure how
they are organized you can see at the
top the board of directors controls a
nonprofit organization that that via a
few you know Corners then controls open
AI Global uh which is the so-called Capt
profit Company open AI Global is are the
ones that actually are building chat gbt
and gbt 4 and so on Microsoft being a
minority owner but a probably the most
significant shareholder of open AI
Global so the board of directors
controls the nonprofit and the nonprofit
is task
with sort of making AI for the whole of
humanity for the benefit of humanity
making it safe two leading theories of
what happened here are one concerns and
disagreements about how to deploy AI
safely with the leading theory being
that Sam Alman uh or his side of the
view was we should go really fast you
know make profit push out Tech and so on
and the Counterpoint being let's slow
down let's make sure everything's safe
let's forego some of the growth and
Profit the other let's say hypothesis of
what happened here goes more along the
lines of who is actually in control of
the company with one side probably being
the ultimate side saying you know we
should go faster we should grow more and
potentially this is all speculation
potentially taking up more and more
investment of Microsoft which might
eventually give Microsoft sort of a more
and more controlling stake in the whole
organization and on the other side the
Counterpoint to that being uh people who
want to remain independent and who want
more power for themselves over open Ai
and potential future inventions of it
this fifth point of the structure that's
outlined here seems to be important and
people are pointing to it so open AI
itself says the board determines when
we've attained aging
by AGI we mean a highly autonomous
system that outperforms humans at most
economically valuable work such a system
is excluded from IP licenses and other
commercial terms with Microsoft which
only apply to pre AGI technology the
point about that I made about control
and one leading hypothesis of what
happened here is a disagreement Over
Control could be related to this some
people might have thought well now we
have have achieved AGI this sort of
excludes what we do from our agreements
with Microsoft and other people might
have disagreed with that and saying no
we haven't achieved AGI and therefore
Microsoft is involved which goes
obviously hand inand with the fact like
if they had achieved AGI let's say they
had then Microsoft would be kind of you
know standing there with nothing because
Microsoft would be like okay we'll have
all all our pre AGI Tech uh from open AI
but this new one they're not going to
give to us because it's AGI and
therefore why should we invest more
money into them it could be that Sam
Alman had argued that the next thing
wasn't AGI because he wanted to take up
more money from Microsoft and thereby
grow whereas the Counterpoint could have
argued well what we have now achieved is
Agi and therefore we don't need
Microsoft anymore but in alman's mind
this might have hindered growth of
course if you had aggi by their own
definition couldn't you just point AGI
at sort of the stock market and then
kind of make infinite money and thereby
you wouldn't need any investment and
could still continue to grow Sam Alman
apparently just a few days ago uttered a
statement here in a speech that
essentially and I'm not going to play it
because the the sound is so out of date
with the picture it doesn't make sense
anyway but saying essentially four times
now in the history of open AI the most
recent time was just in the last couple
of weeks I've gotten to be in the room
when we push the veil of ignorance back
and the frontier of Discovery
forward no one knows exactly what this
alludes to this could allude to sort of
the new gp4 turbo where Sam might have
thought wow this is really a step up or
it could to a new extended version like
a GPT 5 that just steps up the
capabilities of GPT 4 by an another
exponential factor and that this is this
essentially the new technology where
there was disagreement about how fast it
should be deployed given how out ofd the
uh sound is with the video here I there
is a nonzero chance that this is a just
a deep fake there are a few Insider
informations coming about this um
including this one before open AI aled
Alman employees disagreed over AI safety
suke may have felt Alman was moving too
quickly to commercialize the software
another article out of the information
states that more people are now
resigning you know open AI has a lot of
employees so it could just be that some
people just kind of resign on the same
day and are now lumped together but it
is also definitely possible that this is
the result result of these disagreements
again we don't exactly know who was on
what side of these arguments or whether
people just feel like it's good time to
jump ship sver gave an answer to a
question that alleged that this was
essentially a coup by Elia Sater and
sser said I can understand why you
choose this word but I disagree with
this this was the board doing its duty
to the mission of the nonprofit which is
to make sure that open AI builds AGI
that benefits all of humanity when ssk
was asked whether these backro removals
are a good way to govern the most
important company in the world he
answered I mean fair I agree that that's
there's not an ideal element to it 100%
my hypothesis is that most likely this
is about money and control I can
definitely imagine that Alman wanted to
grow faster make more revenue and
thereby possibly take on more of an
investment from Microsoft giving
Microsoft more control whereas the other
side around sver may have felt that
giving Microsoft such a degree of
control was counter to their interests
counter to retaining power and just
again my personal speculation this is
then couched in the language of safety I
don't believe for a second that uh
people are so Al so concerned about
safety at all Elia is one of the
smartest people on the planet even if
he's in the Silicon Valley bubble and
I'm not sure if he is an effective
altruist as opposed to most others Elia
is actually smart and very competent but
what's usually the case is that they
phrase their personal aspirations in the
language of oh this is good for Humanity
like they always manag to post
rationalize whatever ever they want to
happen such that it just happens to be
the thing that they claim is most
beneficial to humanity like what a
coincidence it's always what's best for
them is the one the thing that's best
for Humanity so I have my fair degree of
skepticism when someone kind of
rationalizes their way towards
themselves getting more power and
retaining more power it might actually
be the case that that is the actual
reason I just don't believe it all of
this happening in the backdrop while LM
is reporting that gp4 turbo the new GPT
model has surged to the top of their
Arena leaderboard uh Microsoft
announcing a new language model f 2 that
they say will be open source but as of
yet seems to have a research only
license and Nvidia compressing it's a 30
years of it's It's corporate documents
and so on into a language model you know
chip designs and so on they they trained
on that which is interesting um
interesting approach to making new Chips
but a lot of these other companies are
pushing forward with large language
models including Microsoft right who is
the main funer of open Ai and thereby
it's totally understandable why Sam uh
could have wanted to push and grow as
fast as possible and it's also totally
foreseeable that that might lead to
disagreements Caris Wisher is a reporter
embedded let's say in the Silicon Valley
Tech ecosystem has released a lot of
Scoops that have turned out to be right
so I want to present some of the Scoops
that she's brought out over the course
here saying sources tell me Chief
scientist Ilia sver was at the center of
this we we kind of know that increasing
tensions with Sam Alman and Greg
Brockman over role and influence and he
got the board on his side side the
developer day and how the store was
introduced was an inflection moment of
Altman pushing too far too fast I know
I've not reported on the open AI
developer day which in my opinion was
like the most boring thing ever it was
just marketing speech it was just
introducing new products there wasn't a
single novel idea there which is
consistent with this so it's like how do
we make money and another one saying
board members who voted against Alman
felt he was manipulative and headstrong
and wanted to do what he wanted to do
someone who definitely claims to be
concerned about safety is alir owski
cheering these developments saying that
Mira murati reached out to him in 2022
Sam Altman never asay any such contact
which you know so far Sam alman's been
kind of shady to me but this definitely
increases my sympathies for him elier
saying I stand immediately ready to
double and triple down on the brighter
assessment of open AI says they should
change their name away from open AI so
they stop making Clos itness look too
bad now as we all agree open AI should
change their name to better reflect what
they are El you're here fully cheering
on open a being closed open a stop to
giving out capability hints
um like they did with explaining the
sauce behind Dolly 3 openness is burning
the commons for short-term reputation
gain closed is
cooperative and many many more takes use
sir are a joke and for some reason have
a degree of influence and uh from the
rest of humanity you're doing quite a
bit of damage uh using that influence in
that way seems to be a pretty reliable
source of good decision- making to just
go to alier and do the opposite so we've
come here careers at open aai we'll
search and there it is CEO and what am I
supposed to do all I can do now is apply
so let's fill this
in what is your most significant
technical achievement GPT for please
provide an example or evidence of your
exceptional ability one time I filled
my
nostrils with
water and I breathed out so hard it
almost came out of my ears that should
convince them are able to work from our
San Francisco headquarters 3 days per
week no no that sounds cumbersome so
here we are uh Sam Greg uh you know now
that you have time you can also attend
our paper discussions it would be an
honor uh to have you there and
especially maybe to replace me uh
because you know I'll I'll be kind of
busy running your company so if you know
you have any thoughts around this and
again this story is super developing
please don't
believe uh any things that come out take
them with a grain of salt and it's very
likely we may never exactly know what
happened and even less likely that we
may know why it happened it seems that
so far going forward open AI may take a
a bit of a different direction either a
more independent one a more safe uh one
or it may just be someone else that now
has the power and things will continue
exactly as they were it's going to be an
interesting time leave a comment leave a
like share the video out and see you
around bye-bye